rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message get after it
over to you Joe Rogan a lot of things
and what I found that the best way to
live my life for me some people really
love their life to sit around when I sit
around if I don't like me I like to get
things done but the things that I do
their recreational they're all fun like
Disneyland was fun as with my kids um
Eddie Bravo invitation was fun the UFC
was fun my show sold-out show at the
coffe theater where they do the Cirque
de Soleil at MGM with Joey Diaz and Jim
Norton Friday night fun those are jobs
right but those are fun things yeah and
you know training training is fun extend
up comedy couldn't be any fun er you
know the only real work work is like you
got to discipline myself to sometimes
work out when I don't want to right when
I don't want to this is how I feel it's
harder for me to not do what I'm
supposed to do than it is for me to do
what I'm supposed to do because if I
don't do what I'm supposed to do then I
deal with regret and doubt I've done it
before I've done it a lot of my life
I've felt those feelings I don't like it
so what I do is I just don't do that I
just say well what is the difference if
I don't do it then I'm gonna have to
feel like I didn't do it and feel like a
loser so get after it so I believe in
the window of opportunity I believe that
we will have multiple moments in our
lifetime where there's this perfect
opportunity where your skills your
interest your passions all aligned with
what the market wants and it's your
chance to be able to go out and have a
massive impact now you may not know what
that is right now you may be searching
for your passion may not know exactly
what it is you want to do with your life
or at least the next couple of years of
your life and if that's you that's okay
your biggest job right now is in
figuring out what it is that you love
what you are so great at and where that
window of opportunity is going to show
up that's your job and you go and you
say yes to things and you're trying a
whole bunch of things and there's a lot
of uncertainty but you have to say yes
and try things you're not gonna think
your way into the next opportunity
you're not gonna sit on your couch your
way into your next window you get out
there and you try and you see if you
want to go back and do it again
your main purpose right now if that to
you is to find your next window of
opportunity but when you find that
window this is the thing that really
blows me away when you find that wooden
of opportunity you have to understand
that that wouldn't it will not be open
forever because you have a chance to
have massive success and to have a huge
impact
but that windows gonna shut it's not
going to be around forever and so as
long as you are in that moment you have
to push as hard as you possibly can to
get the most juice from that squeezed
because this is your moment to shine and
you will have multiple moments in your
life to do it but you don't want to have
just a constant existence of wandering
it around waiting for your next
opportunity when you find that you have
to go hard and I think about Gary
Vaynerchuk as an example when he first
discovered AdWords in the early days of
AdWords and he was selling wine and he
was the only one who bought the wine
keyword and he bought it for pennies on
a dollar and it generated tons of income
for him but AdWords was still just a
percentage of his budget he was still
doing TV and radio and billboards and
traditional marketing and his regret was
he didn't go harder he didn't push
everything he had into AdWords because
that was his window of opportunity we're
now AdWords is still good it can still
work but the opportunity isn't as big
and so he vowed to himself the next time
he saw that opportunity's gonna go hard
which is what he's doing right now in
social he did it on Twitter and he's
doing on snapchat he's going hard on
Instagram it's starting to go hard on
YouTube he sees that window and he's
going after I see the same thing for
myself on YouTube right now everything
is aligning perfectly for me it's a
combination of what I love doing or I
have insane passion where I think I can
make a massive impact and we're this
opportunity you guys are tuning in
you're loving it hopefully you know
you're getting an impact and value from
it I have no business having this
channel I'm so grateful for it I think
the big TV studios in a big movie
studios should never have allowed this
to happen for me they should be doing
this
they have decades of experience and huge
teams of editors and researchers and
they know how to work the camera and
they know how to create moving pieces
and put it all together an amateur like
me has no business existing but I do
because they're slow
so this is my moment to do great things
and that's why I pushed so hard team oh
no we don't eat paper right come here
we don't eat paper right okay we're
gonna be a good boy okay good boy and
that's why I pushed so hard that's why
I'm making three videos every single day
because this is my moment this is my
window to do something great to have a
huge impact and I don't want to let it
pass I don't want to be the guy in five
years or seven years or ten years
looking back and say I mean that YouTube
thing I was doing was awesome and if I
just pushed it harder if I just put more
attention on if I just cared a little
bit more I could have had so much
greater an impact and so I encourage you
to do the same thing if you don't know
your window again that's your main job
is to find out what that is and it's
okay to have uncertainty and lack of
clarity and you have to say yes and try
things and explore until you find it but
when you find it when you find that
thing that you know you love doing it
can have a big impact then you have to
go all-in you have to push as hard as
you physically can for as long as you
can because that windows gonna close and
when it does if you haven't given
everything you've got you're gonna live
the rest of your life and regret so the
question of the day today is I'm curious
what is the most recent window of
opportunity for you maybe you're living
it right now maybe you see it's so
clearly right in front of you right now
I'd love to know what that is or maybe
you don't know what it is but you've had
one in the past that you really killed
or you're living in some kind of regret
because you didn't push hard enough what
was the most recent window of
opportunity for you please share it
below I'd love to hear from you down in
the comments I also want to give a quick
shout out to Jordan Toma Sony Thank You
Jordan so much for picking up a copy of
my book your one word and putting it up
on Twitter and sharing that video I
really appreciate your support man and
I'm so glad you enjoyed my book so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
let's pray so give me go
take action whatever you want to do
whatever you're thinking about it you
will not get it until you take action
make that move
make it a small step if you want a house
go get a rug you know I mean if you want
a new car go get some car freshener take
action make this thing happen for you
and it will happen action action action
you know one thing that you know I can
really attribute to every failure in my
life whether it be personal financial in
any kind of way business whatever it's
because of a lack of my attempt to take
action I did not take action and it kind
of changed once I got the fact that
action is the key it changed my life in
many many ways because the resources had
been so limited for so long there were a
lot of people who would say God if I
only had access to a camera I would make
a movie there's a lot of talk about I
remember when I was in college I spend
most of my time in my room writing
screenplays really bad screenplays but I
was in my room doing that when I prize
should have been studying or something
there were a lot of people I remember at
parties who would talk about writing and
that they wanted to be writer but I
would always notice they were out every
time I would happen to go out they would
always be out and they I just know that
that there are people who talk about
what they would do if but they're not
actually doing the thing and so it's a
lot easier to actually write a
screenplay than you think it is might
not be good but most people talk about
writing screenplays but don't actually
write them the people who write them
you're already like in you know the top
10% cuz you actually have written it
don't wait go do it
act now and really accepting we need you
we need you we need you you are the 1%
you're the percent that says I'm gonna
wake up you are the lightworkers you are
the ones that have accepted this call in
this lifetime at this time you have
decided to wake up and chosen to say yes
I'm here to be a greater service than
to feed myself right I'm here to feed
the world I'm here to give love I'm here
to be an expression of that truth don't
hold that back
don't play small we can't we need you
and so really if you are anyone in this
room who has been sitting on that book
idea waiting a little bit longer before
you start that teacher training or doing
ten more teacher trainings before you
actually teach if that's you guys start
and the pressure will be off I can't
begin to tell you I could cry just
saying this p'mote the day I taught ego
Eradicator I was two weeks into my
teacher training and I said f it let's
go and I just went and I felt so much
pressure off I felt so much lift because
I just knew I felt this technology must
be shared I can't hold it I can't keep
it for myself I can't just sit in my
apartment by myself like this I got to
give this and sharing it the pressure
this just lifted it was like oh thank
you thank you thank you and I wasn't the
perfect teacher and I look back and I
was teaching Kegel Eradicator wrong
everyone's arms were like this everyone
was breathing backwards it was a mess
but I did it and I started and in those
moments when we just get to go just go
the pressure is off and then we clear
the path and we are guided to the next
right action and that is the most
magnificent thing we could do right now
[Music]
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple that would be like a little beacon
hey believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details